it does seem like post-modernism is the
source code
that's underwritten everything and then
what you've got on top of that are some
apps
so very very nice nice way of putting it
yes yeah so you have the particular
operating system that's post-modernism
and then you have
give us some of the apps what are some
of the apps that people have downloaded
onto their social justice phone
sure so so for example anything with the
trans
prefix becomes an instantiation of it's
my truth there is no truth right so
there is transgender now by the way when
i say this that doesn't mean that i'm
negating the fact that there is such a
thing as
transgender people and there is such a
thing as we should not
we should not be bigoted against them
and they should live free of bigotry so
one doesn't imply the other but for
example when in the pursuit of
transactivism
you negate biological realities that the
average
three day old newborn pigeon knows then
that becomes a problem right
so you have to be able to chew and walk
at the same time i could fully i could
be fully liberal and supportive of
transgender
rights while also saying look if you're
270 pounds and six foot four
and suddenly you call yourself a woman
no you can't
compete against biological women and it
doesn't make you a transphobe
my my very young children look at this
quizzically and they don't understand it
are they transphobes are they hitler's
so so that would be one example radical
feminism is another
perfect manifestation of this right in
the pursuit of equality under the law
which we should all support that doesn't
mean that we reject that there
are innate sex differences but most
radical feminists
think that by giving leeway
to the possibility that men and women
might be different
different this opens the door to
maintaining the sexist patriarchal
status quo
no we can recognize that men and women
are equal under the law and there
shouldn't be any institutional bigotry
while also recognizing that there is
such a thing called sexual selection
darwin which basically says that we have
evolved
many things similarly but many things
differently precisely because
we are a sexually reproducing species so
these would be a few examples you want
me to give you more or
no i think we've got we've got some good
ones there it seems to me
that the the pernicious thing
about these ideas is that they've got a
kernel of truth
right and is that the the delivery
mechanism
is that the delivery mechanism of the
parasite so give me an example of
how rejecting that only women could
menstruate could have a kernel of
children
so for instance with regards to the
trans rights we want to ensure that
people who are transgender are treated
fairly equally in society with radical
feminism everyone believes that
women perhaps in the past there were
some particular prejudices that they had
to battle against
movement those they're fairly objective
you couldn't vote you couldn't do
x y and zed but it's when that gets
turned up to
1111 uh
sorry that's it just that there's
kernels of truth
most of which appear to be kind of
archaically grandfathered in
yeah i would say that they're different
objectives it's not that
the objective of seeking social justice
in the true sense of the term not in the
pejorative social justice warriors
that is something that we should all
seek if we are you know rational liberal
you know good-hearted people in the
pursuit of that
objective we never murder
truth we never rape truth
that's the problem is that what they do
is they conflate the pursuit of social
justice
with a consequentialist ethic right
which basically says
it doesn't matter if i murder and rape
truth
in the service of this more laudable
goal
called social justice no as a purist
i'm an a true classical liberal
person i believe in the rights of
transgender people
but without sacrificing a millimeter
of my commitment to truth to science to
logic
the common sense to rationality so
that's why i
separate these these two things why the
parasite
analogy so the parasite analogy is
exactly as i said stemming from the
neuroparasitology literature which
demonstrates that
you know it's almost science fiction
right you can have this parasite
now by the way the reason why i say
neuroparasitology because parasites
can take hold in different parts of your
body right so you can have a tapeworm
that's in your gut right so
neuroparasites are ones that
seek the brain because as part of their
reproductive cycle this is where they
have to kind of go so there's a parasite
that will infect the brains of certain
uh
insects causing these insects who are
otherwise very
waterphobic to jump into the water
as if they're kind of committing hara
you know kamikaze thing
they hate the water because the parasite
needs the water to then complete its
reproductive cycle
so it is rewiring your circuitry
to its benefit well idea pathogens are
doing the exact same thing right
they can take a otherwise supposedly
functioning human being
and then you can have these idiotic
ideas infect your brain
so that you could become a mush of
[ __ ] so that you
instead of instead of jumping into the
the water
as the insect does you now jump off the
abyss of infinite lunacy right
so uh you know all borders are racists
well
there is this thing called countries and
nations
and countries have borders and last i
checked it wasn't only the nazis
who were condoning borders but i can
walk with you
on university campuses where that is the
official position
borders are a form of white supremacy
so when people start saying things that
are
so such departures from common sense
then the parasitology analogy is really
quite an aft one
you